i guess  so she's got an axe to grind she wants  to there to be hidden variable models  she they want reality to be that way she  and some other people  and so they are searching around for any  way that they can  to try to find squirrel room where  belle's  their in her case bell serum  notwithstanding  you can still have a hidden variable  model  and  i just don't see the point it's  motivated reasoning  um  to and she says it's super free will as  that i view as  vacuous because that's just what she is  arguing for is just what i would always  have considered to be sorry  is super i forget what her perception  super determinism super determinism  that's right super determinism it's kind  of like a super version of no free will  super determinism is just what i had  always understood to be standard  physics  straight out of the box um  i'm not quite sure why she is trying to  make a case she and others  you